تحول الجدل الحاصل حول مشروع قانون قوارب
الهجره غير النظاميه في بريطانيا من
مناقشه لمضمون القانون الى خلافات شكليه
تناول التعابير اعلاميه واسقاطات تاريخيه
فتغريده الذي يقدم برامج على قناه بي بي
سي والتي شبه فيها قانون الهجره بتلك خلال
ايام المانيا النازيه فجرت معركه كانت
تطويق اليها تيارات بريطانيا المتصارعه في
البدايه اوقف جاري لينك عن تقديم برنامج
فانسحب العديد من الصحفيين من اعمالهم في
المؤسسه اشتعلت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ولا يبدو ان هناك تهدئه من داعمي الذين
هددوا بالانسحاب من المؤسسه بسبب ما
يقولون انه انتهاك لحريه التعبير
[تصفيق]
تجاوز المقبول في تعليقاته اعتبر اخرون ان
قرار بي بي سي قد يحد من قدره الناس على
ابداء رايهم في قرارات الحكومه من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربيه